welcome to the presentation on why not
how borrowing works and i think this is
very important because a lot of people
who um even know math fairly well or or
have a advanced degree still aren't
completely sure on why borrowing works
and that's the focus of this
presentation
let's say i have the subtraction problem
one thousand
that's a zero one thousand and five
minus six hundred and
16.
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write the same problem in a slightly
different way we could call this the
expanded form
1005 what i'm going to do is i'm going
to separate the digits out into their
respective places so that is
equal to
one thousand
plus let's say zero hundreds
plus zero tens
plus five right one thousand five is
just a thousand plus zero plus zero plus
five
and then that's minus
6 16 so that's minus 600
minus 10
minus 6 right 66
616 could be rewritten as 600 plus 10
plus 6 and i put a minus there because
we're subtracting the whole thing so
let's do this problem
well we know if you're familiar with how
you borrow is
this 5 is less than the 6. so we have to
somehow make this 5 a bigger number so
that we could subtract the 6 from it
well we know from traditional borrowing
that we have to borrow a 1 from some
place and make this into a 15. but what
i want to see actually is understand
where that 1 or actually where that 10
comes from right because if you're
borrowing if you're turning this 5 into
a 15 you actually have to add 10 to it
well if we look at this top number the
only place that a 10 could come from is
here is from this thousand right
but what we're going to do
since this is the thousands place
instead of borrowing 10 from here which
would make it kind of a very messy
problem i'm going to borrow a thousand
from here right so i'm going to take i'm
going to get rid of this thousand and i
have a thousand
that i took from this thousand i have a
thousand now that i can distribute
into
these three buckets right
into the hundreds tens and ones buckets
well we need 10 here so let's put 10
here
right so it's 10 plus 5 is equal to 15
right we got our 15. and if we have if
we have 10 if we took 10 from the
thousand then we have 990 left right so
we could put 900 here
and 90 here
right notice we just said so we had a
thousand and we just rewrote it as 900
plus 90 plus 10 and we added this 10 to
this 5. and now we could do this
subtraction just how we do a normal
problem fifteen minus six
is nine
ninety minus ten is eighty
nine hundred minus six hundred is three
hundred
so three hundred plus eighty plus nine
is 389
and let's see how we would have done it
traditionally and to make sure that it
would have kind of translated into the
same
way well the way i teach it and i don't
know if this is actually the traditional
way of teaching
borrowing and they say okay well i need
to get a i need to turn this 5 into a 15
right
so i have to borrow a 1 from some place
well we know from this side of the
problem that we actually borrowed 10
because that's why it turned into 15. if
we're gonna borrow one i'd say well can
i borrow the one from the zero no can i
borrow the one from this zero no i could
borrow it from here but this is i'm
borrowing it from a hundred right
so 100 minus one
is 99.
so that's the how i do it and i say 15
minus 6 is
9 9 minus 1 is 8 and 9 minus 6 is 300.
so this way that i just did it is
clearly faster and
i guess you could say it's easier but a
lot of people might say well sal that
looks like a little bit of magic you
just took that five put a one on it and
then you borrowed a one from this
hundred here right
but really what i did is right here i
took a thousand from this one and i and
i redistributed that thousand amongst
the hundreds tens and ones place let me
do another example i think it might make
it a little bit more clear of
why borrowing works
let's let me do another a simple problem
actually started off with a problem that
tends to confuse the most number of
people
let's say i had
732
minus well let's start let me do a
fairly sim simple one
minus
20
23.
sometimes those three should come out
weird well we just learned that's the
same thing as 700
plus 30 plus 2
minus 20
minus 3.
well we see this 2 2 is less than 3 so
we can't subtract wouldn't it be great
if we could get a 10 from some place
well we get a 10 from here
we make this into a 20 and add the 10 to
the 2
and we get 12.
and notice 700 plus 20 plus 12 is still
732. so we really didn't change the
number up top at all we just
redistributed the val its quantity
amongst the different places and now
we're ready to subtract 12 minus three
is nine
20 minus 20 is zero and then you just
bring down the 700
you get 700 plus 0 plus 9 which is the
same thing as 709
and that's the that's the reason why
this borrowing will work well we say oh
let's borrow 1 from the 3 makes it a 2
this becomes a 12 and then we subtract
nine zero seven
let's do another problem one last one
and i think it and once again you don't
have to do it this way you don't have to
every time you do subtraction problem do
it this way although if you ever get
confused you can't do it this way and
you won't make a mistake and you'll
actually understand what you're doing
but if you're on a test and you have to
do things really fast you should do it
the conventional way but it takes a lot
of practice to make sure you never
are doing something improper
and that's the problem people learn just
the rules and then they forget the rules
and then they forget how to do it if you
learn what you're doing you'll never
really forget it because it should make
some sense to you
let's do another problem
if i had
512
minus
38.
well let's keep doing it that way i just
showed you that's the same thing as 500
plus 10
plus
plus 2
minus 30.
minus 8.
well 2 is less than 8 i need a 10 from
some place well one option we could do
is we could just get the 10 from here
so then that becomes a 0
and then this will become a 12. note
that 500 plus 0 plus 12 same thing as
512 still
so we can subtract 12 minus 8 is 4.
but here we see this 0 is less than 30
so
we we can't subtract but we can borrow
from the 500 well all we need is a
hundred so let's if we turn this into a
hundred
then we took the hundred from the 500
so this becomes 400 right all i did is
took i just rewrote 500 is 400 plus 100
now i can subtract 100 minus 30 is 70
and bring down the 400
and this is the same thing as 474.
and the way you learn how to do it in
school is you say oh well 2 is less than
8. so let me borrow the 1 becomes 12
this becomes a 0.
0 is less than 3.
so let me borrow 1 from this
5 make this 4 and this becomes 10.
so then you say 12 minus 8 is 4
10 minus 3 is 7 and you bring down the
4.
hopefully
what i've done here will give you an
intuition of why borrowing works and
this is something that actually um i
didn't quite understand until a while
after i learned how to borrow
and if you learn this
you'll realize what you're doing here
isn't really magic and hopefully you'll
you'll never forget what you're actually
doing and you can always kind of think
about what's fundamentally happening to
the numbers when you borrow
i hope you found that useful
talk to you later bye